[Music]  Selena Gomez and the weekend are the  cutest wedding crashers I think people  are gonna be a little surprised over  Labor Day weekend the couple surprised a  pair of newlyweds on their big day while  the bride and groom were posing for some  romantic wedding pics in New York on  Saturday the weekend and Selena were  parked in a nearby SUV and eye witness  tells et quote the groom approached the  car in accident if he will join in the  photos and he agreed  adding Selena waited in the car but  passed along her well wishes so Selena  was a little shy at the shoot but she  and her man haven't been shy about  flaunting their romance on Tuesday the  hands to myself Seeger shared a rare  Instagram pic with her boyfriend here's  the star boy singer with his arm around  his lady in a restaurant booth and  Selena's face says it all I'm a really  happy place it's been good  [Music]  Oh